und jetzt das heute journal
juli 69 der erste mensch betritt den mut
so wie es john f kennedy acht jahre
zuvor angekündigt hatte eine tollkühne
vision war wirklichkeit geworden
von einem mann auf dem mond moment
sprach heute die frau an der spitze der
eu-kommission guten abend zum heute
journal mit nichts geringerem als der
ersten mondlandung vergleicht ursula von
der leyen die europäischen klimaschutz
pläne die sie heute vorstellte ihr green
deal als ganz großer wurf die ganz große
vision kleiner geht's nicht bevor das
grüne raumschiff europa abheben kann
müssen allerdings eine menge widerstände
überwunden werden
dazu gleich ein interview mit der
kommissionschefin doch erst berichtet
stefan leifert aus brüssel
es sind gleich zwei schicksale die von
heute an nicht mehr zu trennen sind
das des klimas und dass dieser frau
ursula von der leyen lässt im
europaparlament keinen zweifel an ihren
deal fürs klima will sie sich messen
lassen
mit dem europäischen green deal stecken
wir uns hohe ziele
die bürger europas setzen auf uns den
wandel einzuleiten jetzt ist es an uns
ihren ruf zu hören und zu antworten
es ist gerade mal tag elf ihrer amtszeit
und sitzung zwei als neue
kommissionspräsidentin was von der leyen
anstrebt ist nichts weniger als eine
neue industrielle revolution in grün
manche sagen die kosten dieser
transformation sind zu hoch aber lassen
sie uns nicht vergessen wie hoch die
kosten unseres nichtstuns wären eine
viertel billion euro jährlich will von
der leyen mobilisieren um europa zum
ersten klimaneutralen kontinent zu
machen
mit ihrem green deal will die kommission
den co2 ausstoß bis 2030 im vergleich zu
1990 um bis zu 55 prozent reduzieren sie
stellt einen milliarden schweren
übergangs vor bereit um die folgen des
wandels abzufedern
denn die grüne revolution kennt auch
verlierer
polen etwa wehrt sich noch gegen die
radikale umkehr 78 prozent der energie
kommt hier aus kohlekraftwerken auch in
ungarn und tschechien ist der klima deal
für ganze regionen mehr bedrohung als
verheißung
es ist wichtig dass die bürger kowalski
und kowalskis unseres landes unter dem
anstieg der wärme und strom preise nicht
zu sehr leiden das wäre keine basis für
die zustimmung zur neuen klimapolitik in
ihrem green deal will die eu-kommission
klimaneutralität bis 2050 fest schreiben
alles soll dafür umgekrempelt werden
energieversorgung industrie verkehr und
landwirtschaft
europas bauern sind schon jetzt auf den
straßen die klimapolitik verlangt allen
viel ab auch die deutsche industrie
fürchtet die scharfen umweltauflagen und
warnt vor zu viel des guten
die wirtschaft hat sich in deutschland
verpflichtet die klimaziele 2050 paris
einzuhalten
jetzt müssen wir aber aufpassen dass man
mit den grünen darüber ziehen dass wir
nicht mehr wollen uns nicht mehr
vornehmen als wir wirklich leisten
können und wir müssen aufpassen dass wir
nicht über steuern es kann nicht darum
gehen an jeder kleinen schraube auch
noch zu drehen sondern es muss der
rahmen stimmt dann findet auch die
anpassung stadt so ambitioniert die
mission von der leyen so groß noch die
widerstände vor allem beim geld über
eine billion euro sollen zusammenkommen
um europa auf grün zu krempeln eine
mondlandung ist dagegen fast ein
kinderspiel und das brüssel ist uns die
eu kommissionschef hinzugeschaltet guten
abend frau von der leyen guten namen
sie vergleichen diesen green deal mit
einem mann auf dem mond moment aber was
wenn bei dieser mondfahrt nicht alle
mitmachen wollen also drei eu länder
polen tschechien und dann haben wir
schon gesagt nee danke da bleiben wir
doch lieber auf der erde
es ist ein gigantisches projekt und wir
wollen da hin wo noch niemand vorher
gewesen ist und es braucht enorme
investitionen in innovation in neue
technologien
das meinte ich mit diesem bild wir haben
bei dem europäischen rat den 28
mitgliedsstaaten 25 an bord und in der
tat drei zögern auch sie spüren dass
sich was ändern muss aber es geht jetzt
darum auch sie zu überzeugen dass sie
genügend unterstützung haben diese
gewaltige veränderung von den kohle
abhängigen regionen rhein in saubere
technologien und in zukunftstechnologien
das tatsächlich auch zu stemmen
naja was den polen ihre kohle ist den
deutschen quasi ihre autos sind denn
deutschen quasi ihre autos da gibt's ja
auch große bedenken von seiten der
industrie aber selbst aus der politik
also selbst der grüne ministerpräsident
von baden württemberg hat kürzlich schon
mal die sorge geäußert aus seinem
bundesland könnte irgendwann ein zweites
ruhrgebiet werden also eine region deren
industrie quasi darniederliegt weil sie
durch auflagen nicht mehr
wettbewerbsfähig war also das sind zwei
dinge die da wichtig sind das erste ist
wir wissen alle dass wir dringend etwas
tun müssen um die globale
zu stoppen denn es geht um unseren
planeten und das heißt wir müssen in
forschung in neue energieformen
investieren und interessant war das
letzte woche die 44 allergrößten anleger
die wir in europa haben die über sechs
millionen verfügen uns die eu kommission
aufgefordert haben so schnell wie irgend
möglich ein klimagesetz vorzulegen damit
sie verlässlichkeit haben ich glaube das
ist wichtig dass die investoren genau
wissen worin sie investieren das sind
dann die technologien die die zukunft
bestimmen werden und das zweite was in
diesem zusammenhang ganz entscheidend
ist wir sind im augenblick diejenigen
die weltmarktführer sind auf diesem
gebiet und das wollen wir bleiben denn
der rest der welt wird folgen china hat
schon verstanden dass es sein verhalten
ändern muss
ich möchte dass wir so nach vorne
schreiten mit den investitionen und
innovationen unserer starken wirtschaft
der soll diejenigen sind die exportieren
das wissen und die technologie genau an
der stelle ist ja auch der vergleich mit
mit kennedys ankündigung einer mode von
etwas sinken
weil damals gab es einen wettbewerb alle
wolken dahin jetzt aber haben wir zwei
große wirtschaftsblöcke mit china und
den usa die eigentlich auch sich
zurücklehnen und zugucken können wir die
europäer sich weniger wettbewerbsfähig
machen
nach china würde ich nicht unterschätzen
china fängt jetzt an den
zertifikatehandel einzuführen was heißt
dass die im verstanden dass es mit co2
die man indes in die atmosphäre stößt
nicht mehr so weitergehen kann also
einen preis auf co2 den
zertifikatehandel den wir schon haben
sie kommen jetzt zu uns die chinesen und
wollen von uns lernen wie man es richtig
macht welche fehler sie vermeiden wollen
dass es gut das geht in die richtige
richtung und wir sind gar nicht
diejenigen überzeugen müssen dann dann
ich glaube wenn man beobachtet wie die
extremwetter funden phänomene zu nehmen
wenn man die überschwemmungen sieht wenn
man die dürren sieht wenn man sieht wie
die wüsten fortschreiten
früher oder später wird jedes land mit
in die richtung einschränken müssen dass
wir wieder einen gesunden einen sauberen
planeten hasler ich möchte dass dann
europa vorangeht bis dahin müssen aber
eigentlich ja dann importzölle auf
erhoben werden auf produkte die umwelt
schädlich klimaschädlich produziert
wurden und vom ausland war
sie in die eu rein gebracht werden
sollen ist das war nicht schwierig
gegebenenfalls neue handelskonflikte zu
entfachten davon haben wir schon genug
in der tat ich habe sehr deutlich gesagt
wenn wir zum beispiel hier co2 freien
stahl produzieren und wir sind kurz
davor das zu können dann kann es nicht
sein dass schmutziger billiger stahl von
außen unseren markt schwimmt dann müsste
man an der grenze wie wir das nennen
kevin borlee tags einführen
es gibt aber eben auch einen zweiten
punkt wenn zum beispiel china wenn ich
das beispiel wieder nehmen bereit ist
selber auch ein co2 preis anzusetzen und
wir haben gemeinsam mindestpreis dafür
dann hat man wieder gleiche
wettbewerbsbedingungen und dann soll die
qualität sich durchsetzen also sie sehen
es muss nicht unbedingt an denen
sozusagen schutzzöllen erliegen sondern
es kann eben auch sein dass wir
gemeinsam sehen was können wir tun um
das klima zu schützen und gleichzeitig
innovationen wettbewerbsfähig zu haben
und bevor wir die oder bevor sie die
chinesin überzeugen müssen aber auch zum
beispiel die deutschen überzeugt werden
gerade bei einer rekordmeldung mit einer
million suvs die neu zugelassen werden
gerade hatten wir in berlin 7000
traktoren mit wütenden bauern die gegen
umweltschutz auflagen protestierten
also da wird auch in der eigenen
bevölkerung noch viel an
überzeugungsarbeit hier nicht nur in
deutschland sondern in ganz europa getan
werden muss
ja das ist richtig die große mehrheit
unterstützt aus tiefstem herzen den den
umweltschutz und den kampf gegen den
klimawandel weil sie alle natürlich auch
merken dass ich etwas zum schlechteren
verändert hat und wir wollen
gegensteuern wir wollen eine saubere
zukunft haben aber ja das ist eine
aufgabe auch diejenigen die noch nicht
überzeugt sind davon zu überzeugen und
mitzunehmen
das ist nicht etwas was über nacht
geschieht sondern wir müssen beharrlich
auch zeigen dass es möglich ist die
veränderung zu einer besseren
umweltfreundlichem verhalten zu haben
und trotzdem für die menschen eben auch
neue arbeitsplätze zu schaffen sie neu
auszubilden neue möglichkeiten in der
landwirtschaft auch zu machen die der
landwirtschaft eine existenzgrundlage
geben das ist gewaltig arbeit die wir
vor uns haben sagt die jung
kommissionschefin danken frau von der
leyen für das interview
dankeschön
das interview haben wir vor einer stunde
geführt weitere hintergründe zahlen und
fakten zum klimawandel finden sie online
auf heute.de nach deutschland um
schwierigen interessenausgleich bemüht
sich derzeit auch der ministerpräsident
von sachsen er will
besser gesagt er muss es mit einer kenia
koalition versuchen schwarz grün rot
einfach wird das nicht
die gräben zwischen cdu und grünen waren
in sachsen bislang breiter als in
anderen bundesländern oder in der
bundespolitik jetzt am abend stimmte in
radebeul die sächsische cdu über den
koalitionsvertrag ab michael bewerunge
berichtet von ihm sagt ein hochrangiger
koalitionspartner dass es ohne ihn keine
kenia koalition gegeben hätte nur
michael kretschmers
kompromissbereitschaft habe die
verhandlungen zum erfolg geführt
umgekehrt heißt das aber auch dass
kretschmer für die cdu viele
zugeständnisse gemacht hat zu viele mehr
ist wichtig dass diese koalition
zustande kommt sind sie ist die einzige
möglichkeit diesen erfolgskurs von
sachsen vorzusetzen nur mit einer
stabilen regierung kann man diesen
freistaat auch in die gute in zukunft
führen und so zählt kriegt man den
delegierten erst mal auf was die cdu
erreicht hat sie stellt den
ministerpräsidenten den innen und den
finanzminister das land bleibe
unternehmerfreundlich die innere
sicherheit werde durch den
koalitionsvertrag gestärkt auch den
strukturwandel im ländlichen raum
verantwortete die cdu aus meiner sicht
ist es die fortsetzung einer
erfolgreichen cdu-politik einer
bürgerlich konservativen politik die wir
in den vergangenen jahren für dieses
land geprägt haben kretzschmar
verschweigt die kröten nicht die seine
partei herunterspülen musste das
wichtige landwirtschaftsministerium mit
umwelt- und klimaschutz geht an die
grünen und für geschlossene
polizeieinheiten wird eine anonymisierte
kennzeichnung eingeführt
andererseits mussten die grünen
schlucken dass es beim braunkohle
ausstieg bis 2038 bleibt die meisten
delegierten sind sich der brüche bewusst
wenn ich mir den koalitionsvertrag
anschaue dann muss ich natürlich auch
mir eingestehen
es ist nicht 100 prozent cdu politik
wenn aber die union 32 prozent in
sachsen erhält dann können wir auch
nicht 100% unionspolitik durchsetzen
dann müssen wir kompromisse schließen
und wenn in fünf jahren es nicht so toll
aussehen sollte und wir wirklich weniger
als 30 prozent haben dann können wir da
oben machen dann können wir hier stehen
und darüber streiten was besser machen
soll
einigen streng konservativen aber passt
die ganze richtung der führung nicht
lieber eine unsichere
minderheitsregierung als mit den grünen
regieren fordern sie die grünen haben
eine völlig andere gesellschaft im auge
als wir sie hier haben als die menschen
sie wollen das macht das
hochproblematisch mit den grünen
zusammen zu gehen
doch der cdu vorsitzende glaubt in den
letzten wochen einen neuen umgang
miteinander gefunden zu haben
wir sind zu jedem zeitpunkt mit unseren
beiden partnern anständig umgegangen wir
haben niemanden gedemütigt wir haben
niemanden über den tisch gezogen anders
rum war es auch so schon gehen
anständige demokraten miteinander um
herzlichen dank all jenen die daran
mitgewirkt
meine damen und am ende stimmt die
übergroße mehrheit im saal für den
koalitionsvertrag wenn auch grüne und
spd im lauf der nächsten woche zustimmen
soll am 20
dezember im land hat der alte
ministerpräsident auch zum neuen gewählt
werden
ja und in sachsen wird auch der
bundespräsident zu gast da wird beginnt
die nachrichten von h 12
und zwar war frank walter steinmeier in
pulsnitz rund 25 kilometer nordöstlich
von dresden
dort fand heute seine gesprächsreihe
kaffeetafel stadt bei der er sich mit
bürgern vor ort zusammen setzen
steinmeier rief dazu auf in deutschland
wieder zu einer sachlichen streitkultur
zurückzukehren und kompromisse nicht als
verrat an den eigenen interessen zu
sehen sondern als etwas das einen
weiterbringen kann und die demokratie am
leben hält ein thema aber auch die
situation von kommunalpolitikern die
häufig angefeindet werden steinmeier
würdigte sie als das gerüst das rückgrat
der demokratie in frankreich hat die
regierung nach den massiven protesten
und streiks zugeständnisse bei der
geplanten rentenreform gemacht und sie
hat ihre pläne heute vorgelegt verone
abstriche in rente will muss künftig
statt bis 62 bis 64 arbeiten die bisher
42 rentenkassen sollen schrittweise
abgeschafft und durch ein punktesystem
ähnlich wie in deutschland ersetzt
werden
zudem soll es eine monatliche
mindestrente von 1000 euro netto geben
die gewerkschaften kritisieren die pläne
und sie riefen zu neuen streiks auf bei
einer schießerei in jersey city new york
sind gestern sechs menschen getötet
worden
der bürgermeister von jersey city geht
nach den ersten ermittlungen von einem
gezielten angriff auf einen jüdischen
laden aus demnach hatten die täter
schwer bewaffnet vor dem laden gehalten
und geschossen mit der anrückenden
polizei lieferten sie sich ein
feuergefecht
die beiden angreifer starben ebenso ein
polizist und drei zivilisten
die dänische polizei hat bei anti terror
razzien in mehreren regionen des landes
rund 20 verdächtige festgenommen
nach polizeiangaben bestand der verdacht
dass ein terrorangriff mit einem
militanten islamistischen motiv
vorbereitet werde
die verdächtigen hätten versucht sich
schusswaffen und sprengstoff zu
beschaffen
die welthandelsorganisation wto ist seit
heute nicht mehr funktionsfähig die usa
haben jahrelang die ernennung von
richtern blockiert so dass ab heute
keine streitschlichtungsverfahren mehr
durchgeführt werden können
die usa fordern tiefgreifende reformen
china dürfe nicht mehr als
entwicklungsland eingestuft werden und
von ausnahmeregeln profitieren
zudem müsse der patentschutz erhöht
werden heute unterliegen 96 prozent des
welthandels wto regeln und seit über 20
jahren konnte die wto größere
handelskriege verhindern
morgen ist parlamentswahl in
großbritannien mehr als eine
parlamentswahl regierungschef boris
johnson hat sie auch zu einer abstimmung
über den berg set deklariert in den
umfragen liegt er vorn
allerdings ist der vorsprung zuletzt
etwas kleiner geworden
die labour partei holt auf wenn wir es
am ende erneut zu unklaren
mehrheitsverhältnissen im parlament
führen würde wäre man so schlau als mit
zuvor der vielen briten kommt diese wahl
vor wie eine zwischen pest und cholera
sie finden boris johnson eigentlich
unmöglich doch oppositionsführer corbijn
mit seinen sozialistischen und
antisemitischen tendenzen ist für sie
genauso unwählbar
viel wird davon abhängen ob boris
johnson alte praxis hochburgen halten
kann oder ob sich da inzwischen zweifel
breit machen jetzt in hallein ist für
uns nach sander land gefahren eine alte
hafenstadt im nordosten englands grimm
upload es ist trostlos oben im norden
heißt es gerne auf der insel und
außerdem seien dort alle für den exit
aber am strand von sander land ist es
eigentlich ganz hübsch und es gibt ja
auch menschen die etwas mit europa
anfangen können
ich liebe es sonder land aber ebenso
liebe ich europa wir sind nur eine
kleine stadt im nordosten englands ich
bin sehr für europa doch der öffentliche
eindruck der stadt ist bis heute stark
geprägt durch diese szene aus der nacht
zum 24
juni 2016 sunderland hatte beim
referendum als einer der ersten
wahlkreise ausgezählt und ein klares
ergebnis probe exit geliefert das bild
der jubelnden blonden frau auf den
schultern ihres mannes ging um die welt
inzwischen sind die beiden medienscheu
geworden aber sie haben jemanden der für
sie spricht ein gemeinderatsmitglied von
der uk independence party eine der
versteht wie verletzt der stolz der
einst für ihre schiffswerften berühmten
sander länder ist wie sehr man sich hier
vernachlässigt fühlt das ist ein großes
problem zurzeit ist europa nicht die
leute dort oder europäische unternehmen
wohlgemerkt aber sobald wir mit europa
fertig
werden wir uns westminster zuwenden das
politische system dort reformieren
in englands nordosten wird womöglich die
wahl entschieden das weiß auch boris
johnson weshalb der in der letzten
wahlkampfwoche noch einmal nach
sunderland kam
hier kommt es darauf an im alten labour
stammland mit seinen black sea plänen zu
punkten dies ist ein wichtiger
bestandteil der konservativen
wahlkampfstrategie ich hoffe die
konservativen kriegen die mehrheit damit
dass mit dem bag cit gelöst wird es ist
ein champion er macht das gut ich würde
ja für labour stimmen aber nicht mit
jeremy kopien an der spitze der kämpft
gegen seine schlechte popularitätswerte
an auch im nordosten
dabei müsste der labour vorsitzende hier
doch leichtes spiel haben
mit seinem versprechen für mehr soziale
gerechtigkeit und sichere arbeitsplätze
mit hilfe einer engeren bindung an
europa als von den konservativen
angestrebt niemand weiß so recht was mit
nissan dem heute bei weitem wichtigsten
arbeitgeber in der region wird wenn es
zum exit kommt steven francis hat auch
einmal beim nissan am fließband
gearbeitet jetzt leitet er einen kampf
sportclub gemeinnützig für die stadt bei
exit habe die gesellschaft auseinander
gerissen sagt er die menschen hier seien
betrogen worden beim referendum einmal
mehr durch lügen und falsche
versprechungen hübschen es ist schade
dass es zu so etwas wie den exit kommen
musste damit die leute hier gehört
werden sie wären jetzt auch nicht hier
wenn es den dreck sind nicht gegeben
hätte westminster würde auch nicht mit
uns reden niemand ist vorher noch
sauerland gekommen und zumindest morgen
bis zur stimmenauszählung haben die
thunder länder noch einmal die
möglichkeit auf sich aufmerksam zu
machen
als gestern in oslo der
friedensnobelpreis feierlich verliehen
wurde stand in den haag
praktisch zeitgleich eine andere
friedensnobelpreisträgerin vor gericht
in einem verfahren wegen völkermords das
bekommt man schwer zusammen ausgerechnet
eine ikone den zahn zu ziehen
jahrzehntelang wurde sie quasi in einem
atemzug genannt mit nelson mandela oder
dem dalai lama die lady wie sie von
ihren anhängern bis heute genannt wird
wurde bewundert für ihren friedlichen
aber unnachgiebigen freiheitskampf am
ende war sie ja auch erfolgreich und ist
inzwischen politikerin de facto
regierungschefin heute am zweiten
prozesstag hat sie sich vor dem
internationalen gerichtshof erstmals
geäußert und ihr land verteidigt
odenthal berichtet sie kommt sie stellt
sich die friedensnobelpreisträgerin die
freiheits ikone aung san suu kyi
verteidigt ihr land myanmar vor dem
internationalen gerichtshof die anklage
könnte drastischer nicht sein völkermord
jeder tag des wartens heißt mehr
menschen werden getötet mehr frauen
gequält mehr kinder lebendig verbrannt
warum nur weil sie einer anderen rasse
angehören
eine andere religion haben als sie ihre
peiniger ins kies antwort heute liegt
jedes wort auf die goldwaage ihre
verteidigungslinie ist klar
leider zeichnet die anklage ein
unvollständiges und irreführendes bild
der situation in myanmar
es ist jedoch von größter bedeutung dass
das gericht die situation
unvoreingenommen und akkurat betrachtet
die situation im sommer 2017 dörfer in
flammen
wohin die rebellen greifen armeeposten
an so fängt es an
myanmar us-militär schlägt zurück brutal
hunderttausende fliehen über die grenze
nach bangladesch berichten von
unvorstellbaren breuer für myanmar sind
dass wenn überhaupt vergehen einzelner
die bestraft würden für ein massaker an
zehn männern verurteilte ein
militärgericht mehrere soldaten
inzwischen sind sie begnadigt
diesen und andere übergriffe rom zu che
ein geplanter völkermord soll das aber
nicht bitte vergessen sie nicht dass wir
es mit einem angriff auf die
souveränität und sicherheit unseres
landes zu tun haben wenn sie über
diejenigen urteilen die in den kampf
gegen die rebellen ziel
unter diesen voraussetzungen kann man
nicht einfach von völkermord sprechen
sushi verteidigt verteidigt myanmar
verteidigt das militär und wird damit
wieder erwartungen enttäuschen denn sie
ist doch die kämpferin für demokratie
und menschenrechte
jahrelang vom militär weggesperrt erst
als die generäle die zügel lockern
tritt sie aus dem schatten der
opposition ins licht der macht steht
seit 2016 von der armee geduldet in
zentrum der regierung
auf dieser weise ist sie auf das militär
auch angewiesen arbeits militär auch auf
sie das ist eine schwierige
konstellation und sie hat keine andere
chance als diese aktion des militärs zu
unterstützen
die vertreibung der rohingya seit jeher
ist die muslimische minderheit im
buddhistischen myanmar unerwünscht als
staatsbürger wurden sie nie anerkannt
aus dem lager in bangladesch wollen
bislang keine flüchtlinge zurück sie
fürchten zu hause wartet der tod auf den
verhandlungen entfernenden hart liegen
viele hoffnungen die wahrheit müsse ans
licht fordern alle beteiligten nur sie
die wahrheit für jeden anders aus und
nochmal 1 12 in anderen meldungen
die bundesregierung will bei der
entschädigung von thomas cook kunden
einspringen nachdem der
reiseveranstalter im september insolvenz
angemeldet habe sollten die kunden nicht
auf den dadurch entstandenen schäden
sitzen bleiben so die regierung von
bethmann warum macht die regierung das
ja ja sie wird abgewogen haben zahlen
oder abwarten was da an klagen von
anwaltskanzleien auf sie zukommen könnte
denn der bund hat möglicherweise eine eu
richtlinie zum reiserecht nur
unzureichend umgesetzt und könnte somit
haftbar gemacht werden
das geld aus der versicherung von thomas
cook reicht längst nicht das ist seit
wochen bekannt
die zuständige justizministerium
christine lambrecht wies den vorwurf
heute zwar zurück aber will trotzdem
zahlen
es geht uns darum dass diese eine flut
von klagen mit langen verfahren
abgewendet wird die auch ein sehr großes
prozesskostenrisiko mit sich bringt
dennis vielen millionen versichert war
nur 110 millionen euro nach vorläufigen
berechnungen sind aber bereits schäden
in höhe von 287 millionen aufgelaufen
die sogar noch steigen könnten die
betroffenen urlauber dürfen sich freuen
leidtragende sind wieder einmal die
steuerzahler das heute die frage aufwarf
wie kann das künftig verhindert werden
entweder durch eine deutliche anhebung
der haftungsgrenze auch ein von denen
die reisebranche einzahlt ist in der
diskussion genauso wie eine verringerung
der anzahlungen bei pauschalreisen die
jetzt betroffenen urlauber werden im
übrigen noch etwas auf ihr geld warten
müssen erst anfang kommenden jahres wird
es weitere details zur rückzahlung gibt
frank bethmann
vielen dank und jetzt die lottozahlen
dieses mittwochs sie lauten wie immer
ohne gewähr
14 25 27 32 36 45 und die superzahl 5
weitere gewinnzahlen finden sie auf
lotto zdf de und zdf text auf seite 55 7
die deutschen handballerinnen haben bei
der weltmeisterschaft in japan den
einzug ins halbfinale verpasst sie
verloren heute das entscheidende spiel
gegen norwegen wieder eine bittere
niederlage
der traum von der ersten wm-medaille
seit 2007 ist geplatzt die olympia
teilnahme in gefahr
gegen rekord-europameister norwegen
sorgt torfrau die nahe ecke für eine
ausgeglichene erste halbzeit norwegen
führt nur mit einem tor in japanischen
kumamoto doch fünf schnelle gegentore
kurz nach der pause und die dhb auswahl
den weiß liegt gegen die zweimalige
olympiasiegerin klar zurück schon am
montag hatte das team von bundestrainer
händen knapp gegen serbien verloren
jetzt muss ein unentschieden her fürs
halbfinale doch der treffer zum 29 32
durch michael schmelzer fünf minuten vor
schluss ist der letzte für die deutschen
frauen mit 32 29 gewinnt norwegen haben
freitag geht es für deutschland gegen
schweden noch um platz sieben nur wer
gewinnt nimmt im märz am olympia
qualifikationsturnier teil
das was man uns gleich geht es im
auslandsjournal weiter unter anderem mit
einer recherche zum jeffrey epstein
skandal die einblicke liefert in ein
system von macht und missbrauch dem
zahllose junge mädchen zum opfer fiel um
0 uhr 30 gibt es dann heute plus mit
daniel bröckerhoff es morgen auf wieder
sind
[Musik]
guten abend meine damen und herren das
war heute ein orkantief dass island
überquert hat und zwar das tief zero das
windfeld hierfür sie mal rot eingefärbt
verzieht sich jetzt mehr richtung osten
aber über dem atlantik kommt schon das
nächste tieferen und auch wieder mit
sturm der sich zum beispiel im
ärmelkanal zeigt oder auch über dem
mittelmeer und am dritten
adventswochenende wird es dann auch bei
uns in deutschland stürmisch aber noch
nicht in dieser nacht da haben wir ein
anderes problem nämlich schnee und
glätte die geht's hier in diesem
wolkenband das ungefähr von der
ostseeküste bis zur côte d'azur reicht
und in den westalpen kann es durchaus so
10 bis 25 zentimeter schnee geben sie
sehen allerdings auch dass der nächste
kräftige regen und schneefall erst in
der nacht zu freitag auf uns zukommt
heute nacht also gibt es südlich von
spreewald sauerland und eifel gefährlich
glatte straßen durch schnee und
schneeregen oder glatteisregen bei
tiefsttemperaturen zwischen 0 und -4
grad im norden ist es häufig trüb an der
ostsee fällt etwas regen und morgen
verlassen uns dann die schneefälle
ostwärts
im westen kann sich auch mal die sonne
zeigen hier zwischen dem emsland und dem
oberrhein und an der nordsee entwickeln
sich vielleicht sogar mal gewitter
die höchsttemperaturen liegen morgen
zwischen 0 grad an den alpen und 6 grad
auf den ostfriesischen inseln
am freitag kommt der neue schnee von
westen und zum dritten advent droht dann
sturm schöner